[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Hello, I'm Jen
Person for the "Developer
Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
You can now download
Android Studio 3.2 Beta.
This latest release of the
official Android IDE helps
onboard you to Android Jetpack,
Android P Developer Preview,
and the new Android
app bundle format.
It also includes Emulator
Snapshots and Energy Profiler.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for details
and screenshots.
We've released a
client library to make
it easy to use Google Cloud IoT
Core from your Android Things
devices.
With just a few
lines of codes, you
can easily connect to
the IoT Core MQTT bridge,
authenticate the device, publish
device telemetry in state,
subscribe to
configuration changes,
and handle errors
and network outages.
Sample code and a
video are on the post.
We're making it easier to
secure your Cloud Firestore
database with the release
of the Rules Simulator.
With it and the
Firebase console,
you can test your
rules as you write them
and before you deploy.
Screenshots and links to
the docs are on the post.
The Flutter Release
Preview 1 is now available
as we move into the final
stages of stabilization for 1.0.
For details on
external contributions,
improvements from
the Flutter team,
and instructions to get started,
head on over to the post.
We recently launched a new
Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification designed
to address the growing
demand for individuals with
the foundational cloud skills
necessary to deploy applications
and maintain cloud projects
on the Google Cloud Platform.
To learn more and
register for the exam,
head on over to the post.
Cloud TPUs are now
available in two new regions
in Europe and Asia.
And we are introducing
preemptable pricing
for Cloud TPUs that is 70%
lower than the normal price.
Learn more about
Cloud TPUs, including
performance per dollar, on the
post linked in the description
below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Jen Person for
the "Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
OK.
MAN: Just oversell
it a little bit.
JEN PERSON: Whew, we got
some good stuff this time.
Sorry, I just
yelled in your ear.
OK, here we go.